um okay but welcome back to portal to
the LZ with no fish beautify yes welcome
back indeed
oh dear um do you know what my poo is on
we all knew aren't you gonna go there
like last time yeah there's exit maybe
say oh wait just I think it oh you don't
have that many left
oh wait wait what did not like like yeah
it was my son do you know I went I went
offline on Steam and it rang rang okey
look at that ass
look at that disassembled ass yes I wait
it's super laggy for me okay there we go
it's good it's good I'm running so three
more these got to be the most like
difficult wants to yeah oh man look it
looks like our mystery woman in the
poets what didn't you fix it
I forgot are you doing
later here out oh I thought you were
flying a laser I was like wow you can do
oh well there's CA see all that on me
let them eat alright it said we can do
here there's a cube here can we catch it
or I'll do it again
yeah okay it's my cube yes I got it I
got it and I we direct the cube while in
the air
- here yes I'm in Union okay maybe not
the things there oh there's a single
eating like being anything a little yeah
can you stop shooting at me aren't you
just get out there can you just put the
coupon thing without detention yeah yeah
you're right
what it doesn't ah I'll just just put
the coupon the flinger that's for me oh
oh oh oh I see I see
but now it's facing the wrong way so and
plus it's not balancing yeah okay
yeah oh oh oh oh wait I want to jump -
we have to go jump at the same time yeah
I think you need to be here as well
yes I'll jump on this one but okay okay
okay go go go
no but why do you okay are you ready one
two three go go go go yeah oh I hate
three two one oh hey I was quicker than
you how's that even possible
I don't know okay jump No oh wow oh it
didn't break Wow
ah oh okay okay okay yeah about what
oh oh oh yeah yeah that was good
oh really yeah and now what no they're
sad I think we have to I think I might
need to let you drop down here or no you
should shoot one you should shoot one
and drop down oh if I shoot one doesn't
do anything yeah but you will be on the
other side and you can't get back here
okay well I think at least you need to
remove your bovver there and then I can
fall down oh why can't you do it
what I can do you're over there now just
let me find um doh Hey Oh
okay so we got you know I just jump up
and shoot an exact rate that Canyon
which thing oh they like that you needed
come back over here now we have it over
here so we can go through I'm super
confused but yeah sure okay oh hi there
alright so the field it's like ah man
I'll so good at this
and then there's portal surface so there
yes all right and then come back wait a
man you know you're gonna default on me
anything you say no there's I don't
oppose it no I wouldn't call it safe now
ah we need to let bridge which you can
shoot the battery from there I don't
know hmm Super Dave it's your never
surfaces you can do it clear each this
yes but yeah the pitiful case you're
gonna fall down if you do it it's flood
bridges cannot this oh yeah
I'm line is there's no wait another no I
can't there's glass between oh [ __ ]
hmm super difficult hmm
wait there's that no there's nothing I'm
just kidding you know but you can dump
them from there let's fried egg and jump
here
okay do thing but I should just jump
down oh yeah yeah if you can survive
just alright and like come back here
oh wait I need to write don't chew the
way that portal we need it
yeah I want
okay and then we go back up mm-hmm
do it ow
oh I'm s now now we have the worst
timing ever
wait I got it hahaha yes oh oh there we
go there I got alright shoot your other
portal they're not the one you have but
that one which one was it
uh oh there we go
some nice puzzle sorry it's it [ __ ] yeah
that was just to get the scheming juices
flowing give me your filling oh dear I'm
going to kidding Shane's not you are you
so we are on 8 now or six seven seven I
think so there's like one left two more
oh my one left including this one duh
well yeah I think they're safe maps in
total supercomputers but yeah oh yeah
it's Suns
oh there's nine total cool Oh
reanima soccer quite a while hmm how
tall are you test subject for nine I was
unaware they stacked same ways that high
wait that doesn't make any sense
Jocasta staffed in a median height of
seven feet five inches
haploid I was kind what's in here some
gems a ball hair people that your lover
kill the ball well that's just
disgusting
can you kill us there it's with the bowl
throw that crap right
did I kill no jacket Oh ice I clarified
my veil
why would I was killing with a bully I
don't know there's nothing here that's
what we're supposed to kill him with a
laser maybe probably more to bollard
mine's our ball uh how do we get there
Oh
okay and then the cube we will have a
light bridge while super confusing
oh yeah we do have that thing Glee
Bingley we could shoot out there and
then yeah what oh dear
is there any way we can change the
direction of it yeah this thing ah then
one will have to control one when he
goes down and click the thing leading
Lee so basically wait can we get the
laser right yeah you will do it like
that but how do I get in the lasers
question no I guess I need to get up
there and you can just put it like
somewhere else and I'll suck you up but
then you need to be able to play the
portal again you'll suck me up you said
most of all I don't know oh sorry right
there with the beam there uh-oh oh yeah
and I'll jump in it then yeah good idea
we should light blue right yeah yay oh
hey wait okay now other go back go back
yeah yeah oh but uh no actually though
go back I was kidding I was a joke
thanks testing you yeah I think it need
to jump out of the beam here if you can
oh yeah
but at
ah but I can't reach it from here you
can't out here hmm maybe you can suck me
in from there now I keep I can move it
oh oh okay that works what are you what
you I am being held out now it just
disappeared into ah yes yes and which
one do I shoot which colour the time
yeah no we do this jumping right ah he
is I think that should work
yes all right okay beautiful
yeah they freaking fall don't kill me
now don't fish I freaking trust you I
did everything what he's talking about
you ready kill me why
Oh place your portal again first okay
right
oh oh yeah yeah yes
no um okay and then the jump early
dumpling here we go
okay no too early yes and now I will
click and don't you dare kill me again
okay
I click the I clicker learn what I like
uh-oh
okay I'm creaking creaking yes let's go
oh I have a thing anything there we go
put your picture that oh I'm being
sucked down oh okay mm and now we can
kill build it even rowboats mm-hmm
that's nice it's up good
but maybe okay and now we can do so I
guess I can I get the bowl over there
though I don't get it tonight that was a
good question
no can I
this is from